encore pas passé le million et on a des
infos sachez que l'émission coûte chaque
numéro 500.000 euros
400000 euros pour la production et
100000 euros pour les invités 100000
euros 100000 euros pour payer tous les
invités par émission voilà donc ce qui
ferait 500000 euros c'est 4 millions de
plus 5 millions voilà pour le lait chaud
Léa Drucker bonsoir donc 60 ans de télé
vous êtes toujours là
vous adorez les chiens et vous filer le
parfait amour depuis 45 ans avec Dany
Saval
c'est sérieux ça c'est votre vanne il y
a beaucoup de mes amis algériens ou de
mes amis français
issus issus issus d'Algérie qui me
disent bon dis-moi la Tunisie c'était
bien mais l'Algérie nous jamais
oui parce que le bar des délices c'est
la Tunisie le café
on va le garder on va le garder on va le
garder vous me confondez avec Michel
Drucker
alors allez-y continuez alors est-ce que
quand vous avez une grosse semaine de
boulot il vous arrive de dire parfois
vivement dimanche
c'est 400000 euros de production je sais
pas où il est mais parce que une fois
que tu as payé le je vous le dis moi je
vous dis le décor il y a du côté non
200000 20300 et 300000 le décor et sur
les 5 millions de décors en production
je vous le dis je connais allez 1
million en tout et vraiment je suis très
très large il doit rester bien 2
millions et demi pour Chabat voilà
l'épouse de l'oligarque aurait dépensé 8
millions de dollars pour ce petit bijou
là c'est le bar elle a fait appel au
meilleur artisans tout est fait main
tout a été découpé posé pièce par pièce
[Musique]
à l'intérieur du wagon
presque tout est en or
même les toilettes
nous y allons tous en moyenne 4 à 5 fois
par jour et pourtant nous ne sommes pas
tous égaux face aux toilettes dans les
pays développés elles sont partout et
utilisent des quantités d'eau démesurée
orsetto est potable elle a été captée
purifiée transportée à grand frais le
gaspillage d'une ressource aussi
précieuse paraît aujourd'hui
inacceptable
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
allergie au trou de balle
oula
[Musique]
non allergie au trou de balle non ça
vous inspire pas voilà d'accord
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la casserole d'or a signal qui retentit
je vais promis quelque chose que vous
n'aviez jamais vu sur Marc Lavoine
deux fois deux fois
je veux aller aux toilettes s'il vous
plaît non c'est pas la peine
la résidence de Sim gedoc l'ancien maire
de soumon une ville proche de Séoul et
bâtie sur le modèle d'une toilette
géante du blanc étincelant de la
céramique bien récurée
[Musique]
inspirateur de cette maison il l'a
construite pour célébrer sa fondation la
World toilette association
qu'est-ce que vous feriez pour votre
animal de compagnie que vous ne feriez
pour personne d'autre prendre soin sur
le plan santé d'imaginer le coup parce
que c'est pas remboursé par la sécu ça
le premier tous les jours à 5h et tous
les matins à 7h ramasser ses crottes
dans la rue clairement en 2013 les
Nations Unies ont adopté notre journée
de récolte de fonds le 19 novembre est
devenu officiellement la Journée
mondiale des toilettes de l'ONU
les supports de propagande sont parfois
un peu disons le rustique et on va
prendre le fait comme ça vous aurez le
fin mot de l'histoire allergie au trou
de balle le pacifiste oui monsieur non
non
c'est pas Pacifique non on voit pas du
tout ce que ça peut être du coup 8 à 0
on est dans la bonne voie vous voyez il
aime pas les trous de balle
encore faut-il trouver le
vous aimez les doudounes vous aimez
avoir l'air d'un appétit ce pantalon de
la marshampagne s'offre à vous enfin il
s'offre à vous entre eux non mais il y a
déjà eu des trucs un peu dangereux
voilà
quand même 1000 balles est-ce que là-bas
on s'éloigne du réel
ça veut dire quoi le réel ouais on va
dire un monde plus tourmenté plus ici
quoi à Paris et quand vous vous partez
là-bas on a l'impression que vous êtes
dans une parenthèse non mais j'ai le
droit de me construire des moments
heureux et en plus
c'est pas parce qu'on les des sociétés
se créent une accumulation de moments
merdiques qu'elle est dans le réel non
plus
se poser la question quand même
je ne sera plus comme avant il
est temps d'avant il est
temps de
sans faire vous en avez une pour les
fêtes de fin d'année à noter les
spectateurs moi j'en ai une très courte
ah moi aussi
à 82 ans c'était la doyenne de la
compétition Dany Giordano a remporté
aujourd'hui le titre de Super Mamie
elles étaient sept en finale devant un
public de 800 personnes tout de même au
Palais de la Méditerranée à Nice et
c'est donc la candidate des
Pennes-Mirabeau qui a été salué pour son
dynamisme et son grand cœur bravo
[Musique]
la Star Academy